ah
[Música]
hasta ahora argentina es la nación de
américa latina que más velozmente ha
avanzado en la vacunación contra el kobe
19 con más de 100 mil dosis aplicadas
son parte de las primeras 300.000 dosis
de la vacuna es public be que llegaron a
argentina a fines de 2020 más allá de
esa vacuna el país avanza a
negociaciones para recibir vacunas del
laboratorio chino sino farm y ya tiene
contratos firmados con oxford
astrazéneca y con el mecanismo kóvacs de
la organización mundial de la salud
aunque no se conocen detalles precisos
sobre las cantidades o fechas de entrega
en principio se espera que hacia marzo
el país haya recibido unos 20 millones
de dosis de sputnik vez según informó el
gobierno
la vacunación contra cobos 19 en
argentina es gratuita voluntaria y
gestionada por cada provincia de acuerdo
con el gobierno de la de buenos aires- a
la provincia de mayor población del país
hasta el 11 de enero ya se habían
inscrito 700 mil personas para recibir
la vacuna
[Música]
costa rica inició su campaña de
vacunación contra el cob y 19 el 24 de
diciembre pasado el gobierno contempla
vacunar a más de 3.700.000 personas de
un total de 5 millones de habitantes
para alcanzar la inmunidad de rebaño que
el país haya sido uno de los primeros 10
en el mundo en recibir la vacuna fue
motivo de alegría pero ahora las
autoridades se enfrentan a altas
expectativas de algunos sobre la rapidez
con que deben llegar y aplicarse las
dosis según los datos más recientes
costa rica tiene una tasa de aplicación
de 0,19 de cada 100 habitantes el
promedio mundial es de 0.23 del total de
dosis la gran mayoría se ha aplicado a
trabajadores de la salud seguido de
adultos mayores de hogares de larga
estancia y otros trabajadores de primera
línea de respuesta a la pandemia el
segundo grupo de prioridad que incluye a
adultos mayores podría empezar a
vacunarse después de marzo pero todo
depende del ritmo de llegada de las
vacunas dijeron los funcionarios a cargo
de esta tarea
[Música]
méxico entra ya a la etapa de aplicación
masiva de la vacuna contra el
coronavirus a todo el personal médico
que está en la línea de batalla contra
el cob y 19 en los mil 15 hospitales que
hay en toda la republica dedicados a
atender este padecimiento esto con la
llegada al país de 430 mil dosis
adicionales de la vacuna de facer y el
anuncio de que méxico recibirá cada
semana una cantidad similar de dosis mil
brigadas de vacunación recorren el país
para inocular a los médicos de un total
de 10.000 brigadas que se espera tener
durante toda la campaña el presidente
lópez obrador ha contestado a sus
críticos y gobernadores de oposición que
cuestionan la falta de transparencia en
torno al proceso de vacunación que hará
pública toda la información y presentará
los contratos de adquisición con las
farmacéuticas hasta ahora van más de 81
mil dosis aplicadas de la vacuna de
facer y se espera que en febrero
comience ya la vacunación para adultos
mayores una etapa que se prevé no se
prolongue más allá del mes de abril
[Música]